it's getting too intense it's like every
week you guys come out with a new way to
humiliate us you guys want to have sex
with our boobs now you guys want to
squeeze our boobs and fuck them what are
you doing what guy was ever having sex
with a woman I was like ah this vagina
feels terrible oh I wish I had another
one that was completely dry I know what
to do no that's my heart you idiot get
your dick off my heart you guys have
gotten spoiled you have too many options
that's a problem you have too many
options you guys like it's not whack
Amole I'm a human being I have feelings
and juries and parents you guys are
pushing it it's getting more like I just
feel like you never come back from that
having a man's torso in your face I feel
like one day one day I will be a mother
right thanks to the miracles of
everything
one day I will be a mother I will be
holding my beautiful baby I'll be
looking down at my beautiful baby's eyes
we'll be having this beautiful
mother-daughter bond and then I'm just
gonna have a flashback to just a dick
[Music]
it's not how I wanted motherhood to go
down excuse me I have to fix my hair
after my dick hit it you guys are
getting desensitized and it's like I
feel like you guys are getting more
violent toward us also it's like the new
thing you guys want to do is the gagging
thing that's sexy to you you know that
sir you like that Internet if you're
into that just go to jail now
you're gonna end up there eventually
wouldn't you want to put your dicks in
our throats until we that's right
breathe out of you want to fuck my
oxygen supply now is that what it's come
to do you even like me should I leave
like what is this psychology this
psychology but it's like yeah my big
dicks gonna make her gag urine else
makes me gag at night cool gel cap not
that big of a deal